campaigning has been difficult for
Nelson Chamisa Zimbabwe's main
opposition leader some supporters from
his citizens for Coalition change party
have been arrested others say the
governing Xander PF party is
intimidating them an allegation
government leaders deny
the High Cost of Living and unemployment
are major concerns for voters it
plans to fix if he wins next month's
presidential election jobs
opportunities
come from
[Music]
[Applause]
after previous rallies were banned by
the police this one ingueru was allowed
to go ahead coming
so Tuesday that there isn't fairness in
this election and that
because of that we should definitely be
worried sums of albums are also
concerned about EU law human rights
activists and opposition supporters are
worried about this New Patriotic law
they say it's vague and open to abuse
government leaders say the law is
necessary to protect national interests
the law imposes sentences ranging from
fines to imprisonment for those who take
part in meetings that encourage
International military action or trade
boycotts yeah it's not a good law Buzzy
it's serving the ruling party's
interests for them to retain power and
suppress the nation Chamisa used to head
the movement for Democratic change party
until a Court ruling in 2020 stripped
him of the leadership last year he
formed the citizens Coalition for change
party and he is popular among people in
cities five years ago Chamisa nearly
beat president Emerson manager in the
presidential election the two men will
face each other again this August
haramutasa Al Jazeera Guero Zimbabwe